another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do with the foundation he is not  allowed to use  scp-705 for personal gain the plato toy  soldiers are highly entertaining to  watch and it's understandable to be  curious about their potential  applications but dr bright has taken it  too far  he used the tiny soldiers to plant  hidden cameras and microphones in his  colleagues offices not only is this a  violation of their privacy but it's also  just plain creepy and it's unfair to  make scp-705 instances accomplices to  your bad behavior and if they'd known  the hidden surveillance equipment was  intended for blackmail or for stealing a  secret lasagna recipe that's been in dr  giada's family for generations they  never would have agreed